pour commencer je viens de vous être
quelqu'un d'assez rare vous vous parlez
peu mouvement pour montrer peu on sent
que vous n'aimez pas beaucoup communiqué
ce qui n'a tiqué dans la vie c'est
naturel
jetons qu'on s'exprime mieux dans le
silence souvent qu'avec les mots parce
que les mots soient un peu jeté à droite
à gauche et on les choisit les mots on
les choisit assez peu trop peu pour ça
que dans les films c'est important le
scénario les mots qu'on dit quel genre
de petites filles étiez vous
j'étais un peu derrière amazon comme ça
et trévise
j'étais pas de jouer n'est pas légal pas
du tout j'aimais certains de mes
professeurs plus tard mais sinon petite
école
je n'aimais que la récréation
[Musique]
qu'est ce que vous faites entre les
films
la régulation non qu'est-ce que je suis
entre les films et j'ai pas beaucoup de
temps entre les files malheureusement
des fois un peu en tout cas entre autres
maurice en l'insoutenable c'est pas eu
beaucoup de temps je suis parti un peu
en colombie j'ai beaucoup voyagé cette
année que j'ai voyagé je lis je pense au
projet
vous étiez pas actrice vous auriez fait
pas ce qu'on pourrait faire un autre
métier c'est bordeaux qui dit si on met
tous les siens on mettrait paris dans
une bouteille après si on est sisi ici
non je sais pas je pense que je
[Musique]
j'avais cette idée d'être d'être peintre
quand j'avais 15 ans et puis à un moment
je me suis dit bon ben je vais faire des
décors de théâtre comme ça erreur
edit théâtre et dim et la peinture ça
vous rend heureuse de faire son métier
oui là par exemple année qui se prépare
c'est c'est pour moi une
ces formes enfin je suis vraiment de la
mouette et du film avec les os carax
mouais c'est une année de rêve
le jeu c'est une affaire de résistance
avec les sentiments qu'on l'aura
l'émotion qu'on a je sais ça se retenir
les choses qu'on a en soi
enfin c'est pas tout à fait vrai quoi
vous dépendez envie d'exploser mais on
peut exposer mais on veut pas le faire
tout le temps des copains terrain ça ne
vous connais presque trop bien il peut
aussi vous voulez des choses non mais
moi aussi je le vole des choses
[Musique]